one of the most important attributes of
origami is once we have studied and
understood the way paper folds and
unfolds we can apply those patterns to
things that are very different from
paper
i hope by bringing the tools of
mathematics into my origami design that
i can then fold something that's
beautiful
and it's unexpected
my name is robert lang and i'm a
physicist and an origami artist
origami is the japanese name for the art
of folded paper and most origami is
folded from a single sheet of paper with
no cuts or tears
[Music]
i have loved origami my entire life i
pursued it ever since i was a kid but my
study
was science and engineering i worked for
nasa doing research on lasers but
throughout that whole time i had been
pursuing origami developing designs
writing books
so in 2001 i quit my job to try to make
a career out of origami
i've worked on a couple of different
folding patterns
that were round and would wrap into a
cylindrical geometry to fit into a
rocket
and i developed an airbag in a car that
inflates from a small folded bundle
so whenever an engineer creates
something that opens and closes in a
controlled way
they can make use of the folding
patterns of origami
over the years math has allowed me to
realize as an artist
shapes and creations that i couldn't
achieve any other way
traditional origami was relatively
simple the designs would have taken
maybe 20 or 30 steps at most but today
origami pieces can be so complicated
that they can have tens hundreds maybe
even a thousand steps
when i'm folding it's like working with
an old friend it's like dancing with a
partner whose moves i know
that if i move this way i know my
partner is going to move that way and so
i explore the math develop the equations
solve the equations create the folding
pattern and then i find out what it
looks like and as often as not it is
beautiful for me the driving force
is that there's always something new to
try a new problem a new subject a new
shape that i didn't think i was able to
create before but now i think i know how
to realize it and each time i
solve a problem you get this wonderful
feeling
and you want more of those feelings
you